hello
everyone um thank you all for coming
here tonight my name is uh Seth manukan
I'm the associate director of um the
chemical and engineering department no
uh I'm the associate director of the MIT
Communications Forum um which is
sponsoring this event although this is
one of those lovely events uh where we
actually just had to get out of the way
um and and William and and Sarah really
put this whole thing together uh so what
I'm going to do is introduce William who
will then introduce our four panelists
um William yio is uh professor of
comparative media studies both here uh
and a professor of comparative media
history at utre University in the
Netherlands um he is the principal
investigator both of the open
documentary lab uh which is most
relevant to this event and also um to
the MIT game lab uh and in addition to
being the principal investigator of the
open doc lab um the topic of this uh
form is something he's particularly
interested in um he's been looking at
shifts in documentary style um and
Technology from the 1800s to today uh
for quite some time and is right now
working on a book on that topic so um
this is also one of the delightful
Communications forums where instead of
having a moderator and panelists we
really have four panelists um only one I
mean five panelists uh only one of them
also has to serve as the moderator so
without further Ado I give you William
Seth thanks very much um and I just want
to open with a few words of thanks um to
our host of course the communications
Forum um founded Long Long Ago by eithel
doola P who some of you may know for his
book Technologies of Freedom um and to
our sponsors the John D and Katherine T
MacArthur Foundation it's thanks to them
that we're here and actually we have a
convening tomorrow that a lot of the
folks in this room are part of um and a
shout out to Kathy IM who's been a
delight to work with the face of
McCarthy that we see most so um the
program we're in cmsw compared to media
studies and writing has been really
helpful and of course the open do lab
um as well and I just want to mention
now because I'll probably forget by the
end but after this event there's a
reception in the stateus center fourth
floor and it's not just a reception
there are demos so a lot of the stuff
we're talking about tonight will be
demoed there and um you can come and if
you haven't seen it before have fun with
it
uh I'm just going to try to frame this
because I'm not convinced that what
we're going to talk about tonight can be
taken for granted by um
everyone what we're basically engaged in
is looking at the crossroads the
intersections the potential synergies
between uh what's happening in the world
of digital journalism and what's been
happening in interactive and
participatory documentary also a digital
domain uh the folks we have here tonight
and I'll introduce them as soon as I
sort of blather on a bit it it's as I
wrote to them yesterday I guess it's a
Dream Team this if you couldn't talk
about this topic with four better people
so uh it's really a delight to be
here let me just sketch out a few
developments that have been happening
over the medium to long
haul documentary and journalism share a
lot of concerns they share an interest
in looking at the world critically in
helping us to understand how it works to
sort of point out its contradictions and
problems connect us to one another
there's a lot of common ground and we'll
talk talk about that tonight but there
are also some crucial differences and
those differences sometimes impede
communication between both sides um
usually you can see those differences
those tensions when a new medium enters
the world which it makes now such an
interesting moment um as a historian I'm
inclined to look at older media forms so
if I think of when film entered the
world pretty quickly like by 1907 1908
news reels start to appear and arguably
documentaries are around um even before
John greerson baptizes them with that
name but certainly by the mid 1920s when
there's a robust documentary tradition
on one side and a newsreal tradition on
the other there's huge disdain from each
side for the other the documentarians
look at news reels and think this stuff
is superficial it's quick it's ephemeral
it's it's news at its at its most um
reduced and the news people the
journalists look at documentary and say
this stuff is partial it's reenacted
it's uh it's it's it's got a point of
view an edge it's creative in all the
wrong ways and more oress from that time
till this these two worlds have existed
in different camps they inhabit
different parts different sort of
professional societies they inhabit
different parts of the academy they have
different uh rule sets journalists have
a much more stringent rule set than than
documentarians
um they're even studied in different
parts of the University
so that's kind of curious like it seems
that humanists spend a lot of time
looking at documentaries but not the
news and people in the mass
communications and journalism spend a
lot of time looking at news but rarely
documentary so it's funny that these two
worlds that share so much in terms of
their intervention so much in terms of
what their agenda is um in some ways
kind of pass at times pass by like ships
in the
night so it's time to put this stuff in
perspective and we'll take a crack of
that tonight secondly
over the Long Haul the conventions of
both of these areas both journalism and
documentary have changed a lot we live
in a world where we expect our
journalists to be factual we we expect a
certain kind of uh distance from the
events a kind of impartiality maybe even
objectivity it's an elusive uh category
but there's an expectation of a certain
amount of it and yet if you look back
over the last century or so you can see
that the world of Journalism is actually
undulated with its conventions there are
periods when facticity is not exactly
the issue it's about being more
illustrative than precise where
objectivity is not a there's no pretext
about being
objective the changes e and flow and
they and they fall together with things
like the notion of the audience but
we'll talk about that in a Flash they
they have to do with things like
technique what kinds of Storytelling uh
strategies are employed what what's the
use of Photography in in journalism in
print journalism for example
documentaries had precisely the same
Evolution radically different sh in
style Notions of objectivity is
enactment okay is it not okay and I
would say in documentary those
undulations have been more frequent than
they have been in
journalism but my point is simply to say
that what we take as Essences today the
truths that we think are self-evident in
both of these domains are actually quite
culturally contingent historically
contingent and they're even culturally
contingent in different settings of the
world they play out in different ways
and finally over the Long Haul the idea
of who's out there in the seats has
really shifted a lot beginning of the
20th century it's the crowd the mass
that needs to be M massaged shaped
convinced
cajoled sometimes it's a citizen a body
of citizens who we need to who we need
to inform and
engage consumers to be cultivated and
stimulated eyeballs to be counted um
collaborators to be worked with and so
these shifts also occur and they have a
lot to do with motive and address that
both documentary and journalism have how
they see their mission who they're
connecting to who is Their audience so
this makes it a fairly wobbly terrain
and I think we're at a point where Lots
is changing the notion of the of the of
the user is changing that the obviously
the media platforms are changing and
it's a moment that allows us to sort of
reconfigure these uh these two
categories today both journalism and
documentary face common challenges in
the form of threats to sustainability
economic uh sustainability um they both
face pretty significant gaps in their
demographic coverage especially younger
people um there's a series of disruptive
changes that have sort of rippled across
the media ecosystem and Legacy
journalism and Legacy documentary have
both been hit hard by some of these
changes if I think of something like
journalism you know in the good old days
I mean starting from the 1840s onwards
we have wire Services associated press
writers and those wire Services fed the
news as it happened kind of straight to
the institutions of Journalism who then
vetted them who curated them who
contextualized them who massaged them
into a kind of shape and and and and uh
form that we the public could sort of
make the most of well today that wire
comes right to our pockets and it's too
much so what do we have we have
aggregators and we have apps that help
to parse out our interests we have
algorithms that Fe Feed Us strategically
selected uh news bits as they happen
more or less at least as they're
reported without the context without us
really understanding what the editorial
view is um so this is pretty you know we
even have listes I guess they're called
the list the list Obsession that
something like BuzzFeed has and we're
sort of reducing the world to a series
of of steps so the question is how you
know the the how these practices fit
with established journalistic tradition
is a really good question and one can be
critical about them but there's also
ways in which they engage and might
represent something of a next stage that
we've got to we've got to put our minds
to it a paper like the guardian strikes
me is kind of very interesting in this
regard because it is trying to get it
every way at once or if we look at
documentary it might seem at first
glance that documentary audiences are
certainly the space that documentary
gets theatrically is Is Not Great is not
what it should be and on television its
audiences seem to be missing missing
some demographic sectors but if you
think about the discovery Discovery
Communications Inc this is the home of
TLC and and just to give the numbers
here 2.7 billion cumulative subscribers
in 220 countries um dozens of networks
these are the folks who bring us
reality-based programming from TLC's
Honey boooo to um Discovery Channels
Yukon men is this stuff
documentary well that's a that's a in
itself but I would argue to you that it
fits many of the Notions of documentary
that we have this stuff is reality based
it's very much about story telling
stories about them the yield is fairly
thin um unless one really looks at it as
an Anthropologist of not so much the
people in the on the screen but the
makers of the of the product um but it's
got a lot of traction the concern is not
so much the representation or
misrepresentation of the folks on the
other side of the tube it's that a
generation is being trained to
understand non-fiction in an incredibly
storified character-driven
sensationalized but null Manner and
that's the that's the concern that this
starts to become the expectation the
frame for the representation of reality
one last data point a recent uh this
year a study in the UK found that in the
cohort two years to five years children
between two years and five years old
29% watched video online
daily and 45% of the 11 to 14-year-old
cohort watched video online daily now
this is my the sector of the world I
live in and I don't object to that at
all but I find it significant in the
sense that these media be that it's a
sign that media behaviors are shifting
at a very rapid rate and in fact they're
shifting much quicker than we've seen
media behaviors change in the past and
what that points to are some
generational mismatches that many of the
folks in the driver seat of our media
organizations are from a very different
generation and what we've got to do is
sort out how we're going to come to
terms with the citizens of Tomorrow
these kids that are that are learning to
to fa to to work their way through the
net at a pretty early age so we're here
tonight to explore the changes that are
taking place in the world of Journalism
and documentary as our Traditions
reinvent themselves uh holding fast to
what works and re Imagining the stuff
that we have to address the weak spots
the reach and relevance where they
faltered the once platform specific
operations of print journalism and
television or radio journalism and
documentary which was also television
and film have converged on the internet
there's a common platform and the
question is can we find common cause as
these Endeavors These reality based
Endeavors wind up on the same platform
what are the opportunities what are the
implications where can we go with this
new production and distribution
practices bring with them new
affordances we're seeing this every day
if you just track the job market in in
uh in journalism um documentary makers
are moving to newspapers journalists
from wellestablished wellestablished
journalists from well-established papers
are jumping off into startups there's a
lot of churn and Mobility just on the
job sector right now always an
interesting indication of where the
action is and but it's a great moment
for cross fertilization
and and it's a in a certain way although
probably devastating to a lot of
organizations especially when job losses
are concerned it's also reassuring in
terms of a kind of cross fertilization
AC
cross-pollination digital journalism
platforms have proven to be a terrific
portal for linear documentaries and I
look at Jason here but documentaries
which are always in need of audiences
they can never get enough audiences
journalism has provided a fantastic new
opportunity to bring these products to
people who are interested in the world
around them and
um my suspicion is that some of that has
to do with the video form which is
easier to monitorize than print in some
ways it's got its own monitorization
system uh but nevertheless they're there
and it's working and so the question is
what happens how can we start to take
advantage of what the web can really do
it can serve as a platform to show
linear but the web also allows us to
link it allows us to navigate and move
around it allows us to communicate and
connect with one another it allows
people users to also participate and
contribute so can we imagine a world
where those affordances are made better
use of uh in the Endeavors The Joint
Endeavors of journalists and document
documentarians um and finally you know
if we if we have time after all this uh
it'd be great if we could discuss what
some of the new and emerging tools are
the use of wearable Technologies the use
of uh location the other data sets than
just sound and image what do we do with
location data is that part of a
documentary Endeavor 3D and immersive
Technologies so to help us on our way um
we'll turn to The Experts and I want to
start by really quick round of
introductions and then we'll dig into
some questions that will help to open up
who these folks are and take it from
there next to me here is Kat siac a
documentary maker for Canada's national
film board and she's known for many
things but probably best known for her
multi-year multi-project really
brilliant high-rise series
she's here fresh from picking up an Emmy
for one of the Project's latest
interations Short history of the
highrise which was an interactive that
featured on the pages of the New York
Times thanks to collaborating with Jason
and also received Peabody and World
Press Association awards so it's really
been a a a a very important project uh
not just in terms of like I mean I guess
really in terms of the people it touches
but also in this kind of discursive way
institutional way this also brought a
lot more attention to this set of
interactions uh cat's also a visiting
artist here at uh MIT and her connection
is the open doc
lab next to cat is
Jason uh Spar and cof a journalist and a
documentary maker someone that wears two
hats uh and um New York Times
commissioning editor for opinion video
and Jason is also a former night fellow
in science journalism here at
MIT uh and he's as I mentioned the
person who worked with cat to make this
amazing project uh come to
fruition Rainey arenson wrath is uh next
to Jason and Rainey is the depu Deputy
executive producer of the critically
acclaimed public uh Affairs documentary
series Frontline America's really
Premier documentary
series um she's also here with a handful
of freshly minted Emmys and uh that's
congrats for that um what's interesting
with front line and we'll we'll talk a
bit about this is that it's a doc it's a
body of documentary that is on the one
hand the best of documentary but it Hues
to the strictest of journalistic norms
and that puts it in a very interesting
position and we'll we'll pursue that
constraint or that joy joy joy thought
so in a in a sec and Rainey is also a
fellow here at the open documentary lab
and finally fresh off the plane from
London Franchesca paneta special
projects editor at the guardian which is
if you follow this stuff the Guardian is
probably the paper that right now is
setting the trend uh for interactive
work where she's really embarked on an
incredibly adventurous exploration of
various digital storytelling techniques
um really that every one of them sort of
breaks new ground in terms of uh both
technique and technology sometimes even
folding in live feeds uh live data feeds
um and if the if you you may know some
of the projects things like Firestorm
first world war the shirt on your back
she's the only one at this table that
lacks an MIT affiliation and we we've
got to fix
that okay let's dig into the question so
cat maybe you could just kick kick it
off by telling us a little more about
how you as a documentary maker wound up
on the pages of the New York Times what
was that about how did that happen well
it started here at MIT it was um
actually the the the short story is that
um you had organized an event before you
had even called it the open documentary
lab and uh Jason met the producer um at
my producer at the national film Board
of Canada Jerry flahive and I think uh
then we all met together a few months
later in Toronto at the hot dogs Film
Festival which is uh the number one the
largest North American uh documentary
festival and um and I met Jason and and
and we all sat down and Jason said New
York City New York Times highrises what
do you think I'm like yeah there's
there's there's something there and um
through uh numerous conversations
and really wonderful like we just hit it
off right away in terms of um the ideas
that Jason was bringing in terms of um
what was possible at the New York Times
along with some early ideas that we had
at high-rise that we never thought we'd
actually get to which was the history of
the high-rise building um Jason quite uh
brilliantly said well we have this
archive at the New York Times of8
million undialed photos and my mouth
dropped open and he said would you like
to see it and that's how it all began so
so spent a week there and and the
project Grew From that that that idea
but it was really through through uh I
mean you can be traced right back to MIT
so when I gave you a hint to this
question you said you'd also been a Jour
you started Life as a journalist I yeah
I mean I it was interesting I was
listening to your introduction I was
thinking that I've always struggled
because people ask me if I you know I'm
a documentary filmmaker and I always say
no I'm I don't really call myself a
filmmaker because most of the work that
I do is not film and has never been film
I I worked in video not in in film when
I first started um but I also started as
a photojournalist behind the barricades
at the Oka crisis a student
photojournalist which um which is the
the Wounded Knee of Canada really it was
a very very important significant event
in First Nations history in Canada and
um so I've always kind of I've gone I've
I've been I've done what's called
journalism but I've also done what's
called documentary I've done what's
called linear film but I've also always
been interested in in new platform so
I've never sat comfortably in any of the
categories so so this project feels like
almost a a wonderful circling back to
everything that I've always always um
found the reasons why I do the work that
I do which is photography history um
Social Justice and um and mass audiences
so really wonderful project and Jason it
sounds like you look for I mean here's a
great example of a of a project you
spotted and and reeled in and or made
happen through conversation but I also
when just looking at at the website um
you're you're open for submissions and
it seems like you get a I imagine you
get a lot of stuff you've been in
business three years and people tend to
sort of train they they get a sense of
what someone wants by what they're doing
what are you sensing what's coming in do
you get a lot of stuff any Trends out
there what is the public is there much
coming from the public or is it mostly
commissioned yeah so the the OPD dos
section is conceived as an extension of
oped and three years ago we we launched
this initiative to bring independent
filmmakers into the times because we
have a large video journalism unit
within the the company and we're
currently producing about 10 videos a
day mainly from The
Newsroom uh with a staff of around 50
people opoc is a section for filmmakers
outside the times as part of opinion so
we have some different constraints um
I'm sure we can talk about as we're
teasing out journalism versus
documentary um what we do is definitely
journalism but it's opinion journalism
which gives some some more
freedom
and because it's an extension of oped it
is conceived as this platform for the
voice of the public
so uh we look for filmmakers around the
world who are covering anything really
and and can use very wide creative
latitude from
traditional talking head docks verite
animation music or
Animated Storybook rhyming
documentary and uh in terms of
Trends I think the bread and butter is
is the short form
linear dock that's I think what we've
carved out a nice niche for and a sense
that independent filmmakers can find a
very wide audience now uh on on the New
York Times and people are most excited
about
that there are definitely interactive
pitches coming in in but they're so hard
to produce that there aren't that many
and um what was so great about the work
with cat and the nfb is that we worked
on this very early from the concept
stage so I could make sure it was
appropriate for the Times audience and
that we could
actually host the project and that it
makes sense within our infrastructure
and it feels one with the New York Times
there's often work out there that would
feel a little bit like we're trying to
shoehorn it in into the times and in a
linear dock that's easier to do we can
we can have something that's very
authored that would it looks like
nothing the times has ever published but
once you're getting into a more involved
interactive experience there has to be
more um more of a fit ter So Randy just
to maybe extend a little bit from that
and to the point I mentioned earlier so
front line is is prolific it makes
wonderful stuff and and relatively a lot
of stuff compared to what a lot of other
makers can do are are you get and you
use clearly you're using footage that's
sent in or at least that you find that's
not produced per se from your folks when
you need to illustrate a story or where
something's happening you're not present
how do you that that's probably a a soft
spot in terms of that tension between
document documentary where a documentary
maker could probably make use of it
properly framed and the journalistic
mission which is going to be interested
in verification accuracy so how does
that play out in your neck of the woods
um it's such a it's such a great
question so first of all I mean we we
always um have producers or directors
who work on the projects with us so we
never really take user generated footage
that comes from outside and just simply
put it out either digitally or in our
films um I would say the biggest change
for front line has been journalistic
more than um I would say even user
generated by the fact of YouTube and and
the fact that so many local people now
are filming their own situations and
atrocities that we just would never have
access to before um and we have a great
relationship with a couple of local
journalists and other countries
especially Syria and Iraq where we've
been able to just get incredible scenes
from them citizens basically filming
what's happening in their own towns um I
would say that the early reporting that
we did on Isis which was one of the
first films that came out with footage
of what Isis was doing last spring was
only because we were able to curate the
footage that we were finding on YouTube
of these towns being overtaken by ISIS
this is all people with their iPhones or
phones just simply loading it onto
YouTube and we worked with a local fixer
who could then and this is the critical
part for Frontline take that user
generated footage the actual camera
footage and verify it with three or four
other people who are at the scene at the
time the other thing that we tend to do
is make sure that we don't just have one
citizen shooting an incident especially
an atrocity we make sure we have three
or four different people shooting the
same thing which is usually what happens
so if a Town's been overtaken by ISIS
for example and these are in the early
days before we even understood what Isis
was we had to verify that yes in fact
three or four other people shot this
from different angles so that it wasn't
staged we had a situation in Nigeria um
which William knows about and probably
what prompted this question
um in which we were looking at the
Nigerian military's hunt for bokah Haram
and we started to receive um 120 at the
End videos from people who were claiming
that the Nigerian military was um was
basically doing the most horrible acts
and um that is goes from slashing
people's throats to just mass murder um
in the streets in the name of searching
for BAH Haram and the video was some of
the most um visceral and most uh
realistic video I've ever seen I mean
you look at it and there's just no way
it could be staged I mean you think you
know and it's very emotional so we
actually then worked again with two
local reporters who are really our
lifeblood I have to say the local
reporters in these places are the people
that we rely on the most and we were
able to verify four of the incidents but
three or four of the incidents that were
fed to us we found were actually bah
Haram actually um pretending as if they
were the Nigerian military so this is
our struggle is that there's so much
media out there and it's amazing and
it's visceral and it's powerful and our
responsibility really is journalists
first right and filmmakers too but
journalists is we still feel this huge
responsibility to verify and in this
case we took on the Nigerian military it
was great and I think it was righteous
and they in fact then had the Ambassador
said that they're going to finally in
investigate these atrocities so that's
the other word about journalism when you
verify it and you do the hard work of
actually getting the goods it can have
an impact that you just can't determine
but it's so much better than just
putting stuff out in the world in my
humble opinion um that isn't verified
because then it won't have the same kind
of um impact it can't call a government
to task when they're doing something of
that sort so this is really our ethos
and it's complicated but it's awesome I
mean on it's great stuff it's better
than
ever Francisca to follow so you're based
in the UK and what I always what always
strikes me when I when I speak over
there is or go to meetings over there is
that the the configuration of the
overlap between journalism and
documentary and here there's a clear
overlap I mean we have everyone at this
table as an example of of of that
overlap to some extent but in Britain
it's it's a far greater overlap like I
even have met people for whom the words
are more or less synonymous and that's
intriguing but I but you know you work
over there and I wonder if you could
just say a bit about how that plays out
yeah I mean I think in terms of writing
the long form writing in the guardian is
it's feature writing it's it's not that
different from from film documentary and
when I was um making The Firestorm
project I got the writing from the
journalist and I read it and I thought
well do I voice this up as a film you
know as a documentary script because
this is how it's written it's it sounds
like a documentary already um we've got
that tradition of kind of long form
feature writing and of and of film and
of radio I mean do documentary comes in
in all in all the mediums and in our in
the newspaper and the guardian we have
film documentary we have um audio pieces
and these they all sit quite happily
together in terms of um kind of long
form uh WR long form media which which
gives a particular take on a on a
subject and I mean I guess that's where
I see the role of the Guardian is not
just news it's not just reporting and it
hasn't been for a really long time you
know it sees whether it's a written
piece or an interactive or a film as um
bringing a particular angle to it so
like the the guardian's uh mantra for
like a hundred years has been uh comment
is free but the facts are sacred so it
has to be you know it needs to be um
absolutely accurate and verified
reporting but being able to provide some
kind of commentary on it some kind of
angle means that it's not just agency
news and so you know I don't see that as
being all that different from what
documentary is
doing and what's reassuring about that
in some way we there's some members of
one of my classes in this room but we
used a text by Michael
schudson earlier this week and um he was
talking about turn of the century
journalism in the US and he pointed out
that around I think between 1890 and
1910 or so that the Sunday newspaper um
out sells the Daily 3 to one and the
price is about it's 300% more expensive
than the daily and it's it's interesting
when you think today of the ways in
which the the news Market has kind of
been eroded by whatever can shoot it
into your pocket the fastest but that
role for context and for sort of deep
diving for in long form investigative is
is bigger than ever in a sense
it's expensive and as the hatchet Falls
in a lot of news organizations it's alas
the first thing to go but that's the
space where it strikes me that these
where documentary can actually the
documentary tradition can actually be
quite useful it has to I mean I think
that you know people are providing news
for free so there is there's no way that
people are going to buy that whether
it's in a paper or um you know funding a
a film documentary it needs to be needs
to provide more than than what you can
get for free out there so the guardian
at the moment is redefining the whole
Newsroom and its structure into um what
it sees as live and long form so and and
you know short like short form is not
just daily it's you know it's minute by
minute reporting so live blogs or you
know stuff that is um that is is very
short very raw very rough and then very
long form either whether it's
investigative journalism or crafted
interactives and it just sees not you
know the space in the middle it doesn't
it doesn't see any place at the guardian
for that because there's so much of that
already out
there so I'd really love to get your
opinions on um interactivity in this
context so interactivity seems to be a
terrific affordance it's it's something
a lot of people of are growing up
they're growing up interactive they they
navigate the web they find their own
stuff there's a sort of taken for
granted this for
that the the the anecdotal evidence you
get from teachers in the lower high
school and grade school is the the
challenge of long form linear work but
if it's a Project based thing or a thing
where students have to sniff around and
find it they're pretty good at it uh
clearly interactive documentary speaks
to that space you can you can take a
deep dive where you're interested or you
can move on if you're not um highrise
was great that way you could really stop
and dwell on the photos or you could
just s sort of slide across the
narrative
but one hears back as a as a sort of
Advocates of long form linear will push
back on that and say well but then
different people have different
experiences you know if the point is to
develop a citizenship with common
knowledge one of the great dangers of
interactive is that four of us look at
this five of us look at the same text
and we come out with five different
texts that we haven't come out with a
common base some of us have taken the
Deep dive some haven't do you see that
as a problem or an opportunity I think
with with newspapers most people just
read you know read the first few
paragraphs and the summary at the end
anyway I think that the idea that we
have you know dedicated absolute time to
watching things and taking everything in
in its entirety that you've read you've
bought the Sunday paper and read it from
beginning to end is a little bit of a
myth I mean I I think that we've we've
browsed through things through history
and made our own you know made our own
narratives through through that
consumption so I I think it's so
interesting I think some things should
actually still be linear films they're
just made for it we have this one film
that just came in that is an amazing
film and I just watched it and I thought
well there's no way I really want to
break this one up and insert articles
and have this this an interactive around
it because it actually authentically
works as a film and I bet people will
watch it because it's that good I mean
even younger people because it's a cool
film and they'll be interested in the
territory but I think a lot of times
what we're finding at Frontline which is
really where the opportunity is a lot of
times times the territory that we take
on isn't actually suited that well for a
film it's really restricted to be in a
linear format it would be much better
and and honestly like that's why the
interactive space is so exciting to me
is some of what we do is quite intense
and dense and having to actually boil it
down into a film and have to create that
linear narrative is really tough and it
doesn't give enough credit to the body
of work around it so a couple of the
projects we've done that are Interactive
um that I I thought were the most
successful have to do with that was the
form they should be in so I keep
thinking like it's almost like there's
the right form for every story you want
to tell if you're flexible enough and
you're good enough as a Storyteller
you're going to know this one really
needs to be an interactive because you
need that flexibility but this one is
the potential of being a beautiful film
that would Captivate you on television
on your iPad or in the theater you know
I just feel like it's like having that
flexibility is the key and that's hugely
expansive for Frontline never FIB the
flexibility is really key the question
is how to make that judgment um Scott
osterweil who's sitting in the back
makes a
distinction that I find a very it's a
very useful summation of the debate and
he says storytelling great storytellers
have always been with us and it's the
pleasures of of listening to a wonderful
story are not going to disappear but
play is also part of our lives and we
kind of maybe get that disciplined out
of us pretty early but play is another
way to engage in narrative is another
way to engage in an experience that's
that's quite different open-ended
whatever those two strike me as the
polls and wisdom is understanding which
is appropriate when and how does one
know that I would just
say we um have to apply the same
standards to any form and it doesn't
matter if it's interactive or animated
or an interview and I think in when you
talk about
journalism like as these institutions
these are very old institutions I mean
Frontline in terms of the history of PBS
is is very old it's probably been around
since the early days of PBS certainly
the
guardian right
well yeah well old enough old enough old
than 5 years old the times is something
like 150 years old but I think the the
most important thing is to approach any
of these projects with the
same rigor and
um kind of intellectual and
journalistic approach and not to be
overly enamored by the technology
because the technology is always
changing so it's a little bit like if I
was fixated on the camera it's shot with
like I don't care what camera it's shot
with I care about the story and the
rigor and the reporting and the accur
accuracy and the creativity and um and
in interactive piece with with cats we
put it to the same fact checking process
that we would put any piece of
Journalism
through and the transparency issues were
the same as any piece of Journalism and
um I think the formal aspects are
incredibly exciting and and expansive
but it doesn't change the way we
approach anything MH but you're in the
just want to jump in um thoughts from
highrise which is in fact the longest
time that I've ever committed to a
subject area it's almost been seven
years so I consider that a a a really
large documentary gesture from our part
but in the end when you look at the
units of the things that I make they're
sometimes 45 seconds three minutes long
so I I I I like to challenge the idea
that just because the pieces are short
doesn't mean that the idea can't be big
in the sense of of an epic poem where I
think of Manas in Kyan the the Epic
story that's told what a little bit
every night for I don't know how many
how many nights and and it's it's the
the pieces that all add up in in in in
the congre rec congregation in in in the
viewer's uh experience that I I find
really fascinating um and and and really
challenging in in the high-rise universe
and I I think that cat
pieces are incredibly successful because
they have that kind of rigor and
discipline in them not only of in terms
of editorial content but also in terms
of what goes in because it's very
alluring just to throw all this content
in because you can because it's this
ever expanding pot and you know film has
to be this length or a newspaper has to
be this length and you can be very
sloppy about just you know not editing
something tight or just pouring in extra
links and extra photos because you can
and and so you need you need discipline
both in terms of kind of editorial and
journalistic rigor but also creative
rigor as well that you're not making
something so sprawling and unmanageable
just because the interactive form can be
like that you know all the the
crossroads of documentary and journalism
certainly have to do with um among other
things engaging citizenly activity
informing people encouraging a kind of
yeah a kind of Civic sense a sense of
what's going on in the world around you
enabling people to make decisions in and
navigate that world um and there are a
lot of probably a lot of techniques to
do that and we have I think we have
there's there's fairly decent evidence
that suggests that when people
participate in an Endeavor they're more
engaged in it now your projects have
often had a participatory Dimension um I
noticed just even the times print has
digital anyway has a lot more space for
reader comments than they did the
Guardians are I I must say I spend at
least as much time reading reader
comments that as I do the Articles
themselves it's a wonderful way to sort
of gauge how what pieces of the story
people think have been left out or what
they think the cast of the story is I
mean it's really quite
useful what's your sense of the place of
that we you know from with Rainey it's
about and Jason too it's about making
sure it's vetted properly but is opinion
vable should that if we is there a way
to inscribe it or yeah yes I'm here to
Champion opinion journalism and
commentary I think we're aligned with
this is interesting that the the
guardian has a comment section as well
right where you specifically say comment
comment is free that part of our no I
meant within the paper that you do have
a section we have a comment section yeah
and it's just expanded so we've just
comment meaning I think that's what we'd
call the opinion yeah right commentary
but um
there um there is no contradiction
between journalism and opinion
I mean that that's that's
the position of of the section amen
which is uh been around since I think
1970 the op opad has been around since
1970 and the editorial page has been
around for much longer than that because
we have these old framed examples of
them from maybe a hundred years ago but
uh I think the point is and and you were
speaking about it before
it's more El your Mo your kind of um
tagline is more eloquent than what I've
heard which is you're you're entitled to
your own opinion but not your own facts
which is just a rephrasing yeah
and
um we will allow people to
say any interesting perspective as long
as it can be backed
up and also they have to
um acknowledge the other point of view
and we don't allow propaganda I think
there's a difference between propaganda
and
opinion um but I I don't like this
uh if anyone tries to set up uh some
binary opposition between journalism and
opinion I don't think that's
valid but we're at surfaces user
generated content where I mean rainy
you're saying you have to scrutinize it
much the same way that you would any
other anything your folks all agree on
that though right you don't think it's
tougher it's tougher than ever to verify
but yeah I mean it's it's richer than
ever too so it's just a couple of added
layers and maybe it's maybe it's domain
specific as K in your case when people
are uploading like in the out my window
through my window that's there's
material that people have uploaded there
right isn't uh not in the the main site
but we do have a participation site and
the fourth part of the New York Times
pie or history of high-rise was uh
thanks to Lexi Mainland who will be here
as well um who's the social media uh
editor at the New York Times had the
idea to make a fourth piece that was
entirely comprised of reader submissions
of photog of of of of life in high-rises
around the world and so the fourth piece
was made of of that material but that's
not exactly vable stuff is it well I
mean I think it's vable yeah we we we
would ask for uh email addresses and
names and and often when we were using
material I think uh I think the team
went and and and verified the the
accounts and and the people and there's
stuff beyond the photo there there
stories and uh there there are many
elements to vet and fact check and copy
edit and on the archives as well we had
to go through these very old photographs
and figure out who who who shot it and
who owns the rights to them well even
cutlines I mean when you go into Merlin
which is the the photo system that is
used um by most major news newspapers
around the world um to manage huge
digitized archives I I used it
extensively uh with Jason and um it you
can't just take the cut line that's
written in there and publish it that all
has to be vetted and it was incredible
how how many errors there are in that
syst in that data input system where
photographers are just quickly writing
in their captions those are not verified
facts and so there's that whole process
too of of verifying your own systems of
managing all this
data yeah ask another but I'm going to
open it up we'll open it up to the
audience and I ask it use there's a mic
on each side so please use the mic um
and it's a question about new
technologies or new techniques this is a
fast changing domain I know that some of
you have been looking at 3D Systems
location based being able to append
stories to the places where they
happened is is really a wonderful way to
think about the morg also to put that
morg to use and take those old stories
and put them up where they where they
happened any
thoughts on that domain moving beyond
where we are now in terms of uh
technique and Technology I think
something that that we've all hinted on
in in various respects which is that
tension between interactivity and be
becoming immersed in a story so when do
you just let the story take over and and
you become a passive recipient to a
story that's unfolding at a pace of the
Storyteller or the musician have you um
lets it reveal and where what is the
pacing of of the the where you jump in
and have to make a choice which breaks
that fluidity and and that's a big
question in the immersive experiential
stuff like Oculus Rift or documentaries
that move into the gaming space where
worlds are created but then how do you
tell a story within that space so how do
you how do you spatialize storytelling
and how do you storify spaces and that's
a very very big question for
documentarians and journalists alike I
think I think it's a huge it's a huge
point is how do you I mean that's
actually the only reason I'm a fellow is
to figure that out because I think I
honestly because I think that's the
question is how do you use this amazing
technology um to help actually tell you
know actually engage ourselves but also
younger people in the most important
stories of our time how do we capture
their imagination but how do we stay
true to you know what we believe in
which is which is some form of
truthtellah say from a game if you're
trying to if you're trying to as a the
game as a simulation say if you want to
understand the economy like there's
probably no better way you can describe
it I think explanatory work is really
there's a lot of an there's a huge
upside you see that like I have a
5-year-old and an eight-year-old and the
games that they play are explanatory and
they learn so much from them and they're
so deeply engaged as they're learning so
I think there's something um and I've
been really studying how they learn
because I think it's fascinating and I
think a lot of that could be applied to
what we do if our goal is to really
actually engage and and educate a
citizenry we got to look at this
technology because the way that they can
get you to understand what it is that
you're trying to explain is pretty
provocative and it's difficult for some
of us who want to really control our
universe but I think it's it's key it's
key to unlocking this especially for a
younger generation and I think from a
documentary perspective um how do you
make the interactivity poetic I mean I
think that's the
keep thinking about Michael Moore he was
at Tiff in Toronto just a few weeks ago
and he put out a Manifesto about the
documentary and he disowned the word
documentary and he said that what he
makes is films not documentaries and and
I think that's the other side of
documentary that we struggle with as
documentarians is this tension between
non-fiction and fiction and
entertainment and the featurelength film
and how you know documentarians are
really just on their way to making
fiction like when are you going to grow
up and make fiction films is a question
I used to often get and and and so there
there's that side of it too is the
Poetics and how do you how do you how do
you elevate this to poetry and to to a
cinematic um
Artistry I would just add a lot of what
happens with great film making and
Artistry is the emotional experience and
in theory through interactivity you can
deepen an emotional
experience and through immersion I
imagine at a certain point yeah what
scares me a little with oculus rift is
how um all
consuming and how
effective it can be emotionally and and
some of our responsibility in the
non-fiction realm is to temper emotion
with um reality intellect and CRI and be
careful about being overly manipulative
because it's so easy easy to manipulate
the viewer and force them into certain
you know fenals I think that's really a
good it's a good caution yeah yeah so I
think as we think about like propaganda
versus documentary I think you could do
like some immersive propaganda piece be
very easy to do well they have done it
the the US military has made a very
successful to recruit recruit yeah it's
amazing I've seen
that the other thing about technology is
it it it's quite boring but it dates and
your very expensive and beautiful
projects just you know aren't accessible
after 2 years because um you know Flash
doesn't exist anymore or um you know
that it it's not supported on on that
particular phone and um it's it's quite
dull but it's extremely important when
you're making things specifically for
technology and we don't really like to
think about it that much because we like
to make these things of them to be
beautiful and use the latest technology
but it's the kind of Life of these
things is probably something we should
consider sustainability is a really big
issue and I I know we're kind of at a
transition point and I mean we're
watching technolog is changing faster
than we can keep up with it but watching
it play out in these forms is um it's
it's a rich period it's very much like
the first to me the first five to 10
years of Cinema where like a million in
one ideas were tried and it shook down
at a certain point to four or five
mainstream approaches but the trick here
and it goes to cat's point about poetry
if you want the mode of interaction to
sort of work with what your topic is if
you want a a wholeness if you want a
poetic engagement it it's much harder to
work with off-the-shelf stuff it sort of
means you need programmers and you need
designers which means expense and it's
harder to sort of say well here's here's
a choice of five or six you know systems
take one and run with it that's where
you start to lose
the the hiu of uh
any questions from the
audience please uh if you just speak
through the mic behind you
sure well I just wanted to follow up I
guess Jason began it talking about here
here's how I interpret it anyhow you
have material you become emotionally
involved with it it has an effect on you
but you all work in organizations that
have a
particular project a particular ethos
you have you know it has a
you represent a certain value system so
how do you how do you work that remove
yourself you begin to feel passionate
about
something and know that you have to
reform it
into a certain way that might be more
other words you are all in a group
process but individually you push for
certain things that are very that really
affect you how does that work in an
organization particularly you have long
form raining and uh Franchesca you have
New Media so to speak Karina I'll
definitely look up your work I'm sorry I
didn't didn't see it so um I would just
say um it depends like who you are as a
person so I'll just speak for myself
that um uh you know I firmly believe in
in Fair journalism so I don't believe in
objective journalism so I never believed
that like you know a equals B that was
never why I went into it I really went
into journalism because I believe that
especially investigative work was
crucial to our democracy it was sort of
like my religion if I could say right
what that means is you may believe
something but um what I really believe
is the most interesting um work happens
when you really report against yourself
and report against your assumptions so I
happen to love that intellectual process
some people hate it and some of our
reporters hate it when I'm like how how
good is that Source how many sources do
you have are you sure you've asked as
the toughest questions of yourself
because my belief is and this then
tracks with front lines that if you ask
yourself the toughest of questions right
about your belief system you'll get
closer to the truth you don't ever get
the truth I mean what is truth anyway
but you can get closer and closer and
closer to understanding the problem that
you're trying to uncover and so I mean I
think that's why our work can sometimes
really resonate is because we're we're
trying to take an honest path through
really difficult subject that people
have really diametrically opposed points
of view on but if you do that carefully
enough you can get somewhere so I don't
have any conflict with that because I
like that I would build on that by
saying it's also in terms of story
selection that uh at least in in my
section um we encourage all types of
viewpoints on issues so it's important
to also include viewpoints you may
disagree agree with
and viewpoints that are just interesting
I I think that's often what we're
looking for what's a really interesting
take on a subject and that will help it
also rise above all the kind of noise
that's out there so um it doesn't matter
whether I agree with it or not but
that's that's a very interesting
argument and uh you know it should not
all be kind of liberal Progressive
viewpoints we don't sit around thinking
like how can we find more stories to
advance our own pet causes that's that
does not happen it's more here's an
important issue in the world we've heard
a lot of that argument let's now put
forward some other arguments and and
then then the truth may come about
through some of that your question
really just applies to all journalism it
doesn't really matter whether it's
interactives or film or I mean it's you
know how do you be a good journalist and
how do you stay within you know the the
editorial line of the particular
organization you're in as well as you
know having your own ethical values and
I would say you know part of that is
training when I was at the BBC you go
through this you know course after
course of what the BBC line is the
guardian is you know quite not quite so
kind of uh militant as that but still
from working in an organization for a
while you get a very good sense of what
those editorial values are you bring
your own values to that as well it
really doesn't matter whether it's for
what form it ends up in it's just you
know that's how you train as a
journalist I'd say the difference in the
only difference in New Media is the kind
of check so when I started at the
guardian eight years ago having come
from the BBC I was suddenly able to make
I came into the podcasting uh Team
because I was a radio producer and
nobody asked me what I was making pieces
on no one listened to them I made them I
uploaded them then they were out I
didn't have an editor I didn't have
anyone and so suddenly you know from
having these
really quite strict process they have
for the writers going through you know
um subs and editors and commissioning
editors you know I had none of that so I
think that and and I was you know has
that
changed a
little but I mean still no one checks me
I commission my own pieces and make them
and put them out and I just don't Mak so
many now but um yeah no it's that's
interesting because you know the these
are new kind of slightly Wild West areas
of
you know one of the wonderful things
about working for somewhere like the
guardian I'm not sure just like at New
York Times is you have this kind of huge
established organization which has got
wonderful resources in it but because
it's a new area it is quite Wild West
likee you've got this incredible
flexibility and freedom as well so um
you need to be quite careful of your of
of having strong journalistic kind of
Standards there but I I would just say
that you know your question is really
just quite a general one one on about
journalism in my
opinion
um if you could go up to the mic and
then yeah Ana great uh my question is
for Rainey but by no means restricted to
you um I you gave a really interesting
example of working with user generated
content and that's something that I've
done a lot of and I'm really interested
in and uh I was curious to ask you um a
little bit more about how in situations
where you're working with users
potentially in extremely risky
environments do you talk to them about
things like personal safety how do some
of those conversations take place and
how do you handle some of those very
sticky issues that's a really really
great question and it came up both in
the Isis story and also in the bah Haram
story um we we actually track down the
people who have given the footage
usually to an intermediary so we find
the actual people who filmed it before
we put anything out on on front line and
and we go through the same consenting
process that we would with an interview
in most of those cases we did obscure
identities so we made sure that anybody
who is
identifiable um as either the the
citizen themselves or somebody in the
shop that we thought was inadvertently
going to be accused of anything we would
we would certainly and we did a lot of
it BL a lot of people especially in the
boa Haram story but we have the same
process we care a lot about I mean we
actually I mean we care as much about
the people filming right themselves on
their own iPhones as we do our own
producers and reporters in fact they're
much more vulnerable than our
journalists because we um can get our
journalists out usually not all the time
as you guys have seen lately um but I I
do think that we take it very seriously
I think a lot of them are not educated
about the risk they're taking so we go
above and beyond and um we have been
really fortunate knock on wood with the
with that process but I think it's
really important
yeah that's great thank you
sure
Jim please yeah yeah um Jim par uh
thanks comparative media studies I'm
very interested in um how you all think
about audience because obviously
audiences are the great unknown they
change they shift and so forth and I'm
very curious about how audience comes
into the picture as you think about your
work and the crafting of the work uh so
that's the first part of the question
second part of the question is with
interactivity how does that formula or
whatever if you have a formula or if you
have a practice how does that shift so
I'll just keep that
simple I I have an audience we we have a
very unusual audience and um I think
everybody has a different different
audience is here so I think every I hope
everybody will answer but for Frontline
um we still have a very vital broadcast
and a lot of people still watch us
Millions every week come to Frontline on
television they watch us in real time
that's kind of amazing to me because I
never do anything in real time anymore
um but what's remarkable is that that's
that's our sort of core audience and
they come every single time we have a
fresh film um what's been really amazing
for us is digitally our audience is
going through the roof like the numbers
are incredible and that audience is much
younger um they tend to be in their 20s
and 30s and early 40s and they come to
us and they do all sorts of different
things in our television audience they
love to give us their email because we
don't fundraise off of them and they
love to interact with us online which I
find to be the most incredible thing
that all of a sudden we have a very
active community so um that's our
growing community so we think about them
all the time and that means we do um
different things actually we put things
in shorter form but I think we should do
that anyway so it's not like we're just
serving the audience but we do all sorts
of things like publish daily as opposed
to just waiting for a big film to come
out and we noticed that this audience
also loves our longer form films so they
come they they watch for an incredible
length of time but like you said this
there's a myth that people watch the
whole thing even on television right
well we don't know what people are doing
in their living rooms they could be
going and getting a Coke or coffee or
whatever but you can tell when people
are watching online a little bit better
and they stay for a while so it's pretty
it's a pretty um optimistic Trend
watching how our audience is growing
online I can say the same for the
national film Board of Canada we we sort
of did two very large digit digitizing
projects at the same time one was begin
creating work specifically for the
digital space we have Beyond high-rise
there's two other Studios there's a
there's an English digital studio and a
French dig digital Studio that produced
specifically digital work but the other
thing that the nfb has done has gone
into to its 75 year history and pulled
out over I think 3 or 4,000 films now
and streamed them online um and that's a
that was a mammoth project in terms of
Rights and clearing everything and
getting it up and running um but we find
our audiences very similar to yours that
um the completion rates are phenomenal
people watch long form for a long time
on online we don't have any problems
with that at all um and then the other
part of our the the interactive work
that we've created the documentaries um
specifically made for digital space um
usually our first audience we have
multiple a we call them sort of ripple
effect audiences so our first audiences
tend to be early adopters so people that
are interested in the technology so for
example um I made the first webgl
documentary several years ago called 1
millionth Tower it was featured on
wire.com for 48 hours because of the
technology we used but the tweet that
really represents how our audience has
reacted to the work is that um somebody
said I came for the technology stayed
for the story and so then once once
people are kind of interested people
that are really into technology they oh
webgl is so cool they're like oh wait a
second this is about City renewal and
and urban planning and citizenship and
they got really into it and linked it to
their own ideas about technology um and
then you get the Educators and then you
get the fivey we've had tweets from
five-year-olds talking about spending
you know 40 minutes on out my window so
it really ripples out um but definitely
in our experience usually it's the
people that are really interested in
technology because those are the people
that are on on the net looking for new
stuff so that's bit of explanation of
ours I would add two two quick things um
a huge buzzword around our office these
days is audience development where we
have a new Mast head position which is
like one of the most senior editors
Staffing up a whole group now in trying
to find new ways of reaching people with
New York Times content so this is like a
really big idea that we're exploring but
the other thing is how do you give kind
of pleasure and satisfaction to to your
audience not just reaching more people
but how do you kind of satisfy them and
challenge them and I think that's that's
the most fun thing to kind of test their
interests and um broaden the sense of of
what you can publish because like I have
the I feel fortunate to be able to
experiment and do things where people
say wow I I never expected the New York
Times to do that um well the rhyme
couplet is a really good example the
rhyming cup yes who would have expected
some people hated that terms of the
audience about half our comments are how
much they hate rhyming and why is the
New York Times doing a rhyming story
book but that's okay I don't come to the
New York front pages of the New York
Times to get you know Rhymes but then
that's also com that's an interesting um
uh example of how who comments you know
who are your commenters on a site those
aren't NE that's not necessarily the
general audience if you went to Twitter
you weren't we didn't see that kind of
commentary because on Twitter you
probably seeing new audiences talking
about a New York Times piece whereas
commenters were more likely the the
hardcore New York Times readers who
found this out of the ordinary so to
kind of gauge who you're listening to
and where they're coming from as well
that's a really good point I mean
different groups are all I mean
definitely the Twitter audience is very
different than those who comment on our
website are different from our Facebook
audience are different from the people
who comment on YouTube I mean it's a
totally different the YouTube comments
are really
interesting they're they're really
supportive of our extreme journalism in
the field they love it like when you
know you know it's when it's more I
suppose I don't like to say Vice like
because we're Frontline but actually I
love Vice and I watch Vice but the point
is they love that kind of work when it's
really visceral they're much less
interested when we have Talking Heads in
our films and they just tell us you know
this is boring they're not into it all
right we hear you you so eleth thank you
thanks for letting me stay in my chair
and use the mic so I had two questions
um Randy was very eloquent about having
flexibility and choice about uh uh
regular kind of linear storytelling
versus interactive and she said what
kind of in a way what kind of uh piece
was good for linear I was wondering from
any of you what kind of a story is most
um is best treated as an interactive
story so so that was my first question
for any of you and the second is none of
you have really talked about platform
and how your audiences are are
interacting with your material what
devices what you know and does that
matter in terms of how you are producing
what you're
doing want I go
first maybe go ahead for story should I
talk about platform because um yeah you
know you know something that we're
really obsessed by the guardian because
everyone is now moving on to mobile I
mean that's the general Trend anyway but
you know people for news are checking
their phones you know several times a
day on mobile and it's a huge challenge
when we want to make these really
beautiful fancy interactives and what
does that look like on a really tiny
screen um so you know we're being really
encouraged to think about making trying
to make some projects next year that
maybe you know come from a mobile point
of view I I mean I think for us there
kind of wearable technology and and
things like that are are going to be
exciting but really mobile is the key
for us at the
moment and I would say the tablet for
front line is the most friendly right
now in the Forum that we are most which
is the linear Dock and so it's just
because people are leaning back and
experiencing the films and those numbers
have like
skyrocketed um and I think on smaller
phones and mobile people are watching
for longer than you would think and we
have the same Challenge on interactive
and we have the same project where we're
looking at shorter form interactive but
I would say journalistically why I like
interactive so much is especially when
we're doing collaborations with our
partners at the New York Times and other
places I'm finding a very comfortable
home in the interactive space to do
truly collaborative work with our text
partners and still photographers and
people so that we can combine our
mediums that's where I'm the most
excited is when we're working with like
the prop publicas and those folks where
we're trying to think about how can we
crack our own forms together when the
reporting is really deep and when I feel
like the linear documentary can can
restrict it is really just amazing like
what the potential is with our partners
that's where I'm most
excited well what in terms of platform
some of our
work um is around half mobile
um half the audience is on mobile so
it's friendly it's not a theoretical
question at all we are dealing it with
this week um looking at the the you know
desktop experience and the mobile
experience and it's very challenging U
as you're designing because you want to
have cross-platform pieces and you and
you want to serve up The Full Experience
on mobile without what you can't do is
is put up
a a black card that says go go to your
laptop computer to watch this video you
have to give them something well I did
that two years ago for a project and I
just got hauled in and said you can
never do that again you can't make a
Guardian Project that does not work on
mobile it's not allowed because you lose
half of the audience and thinking about
gesture and and with maybe you could
talk about how you thought about tablet
with highrise yeah the the concept for
the highrise the short history of
highrise was was um inspired by the
story books the children's books that
have been developed for tablets and uh
so that was the that was kind of the
tactile inspiration for it and um Jackie
mint who is the phenomenal designer and
developer at the New York Times with
whom I had the pleasure of working um uh
we we we worked out a way in which we
could do that in browser so um that you
don't have to download an app or it's
all right there um and there's real
limitations even in a very you know the
the the it was beautifully coded and
beautifully designed but technologically
it wasn't actually that complex um but
even still there were some really big uh
constrictions especially on audio you
can't do any cross Fades on mobile you
have to trigger every video like there's
just all these things that really limit
the a rich experience in the mobile
environment that that uh we're just
really waiting for for the webg and for
the the the power of the mobile to to
kind of catch up to to the kinds of
things that we're able to do on desktop
so that's a huge limitation for me as an
artist working in the mobile World
gesture you're able to use gesture an
interesting touching yeah but we have to
the technology has to catch up because
everybody's on mobile so we're waiting
we're almost waiting you know it's so
interesting as people are just in droves
going to Mobile in smaller format it's
just then if the technology catches up
with our Creative Visions that would be
that will happen that's why we're at MIT
right exactly you hi um my question is
about the audience perception and the
ethical issues like you just said with
micro mode he claims what he made is not
documentary that's just film but the
audience won't think so maybe you think
oh you are a documentary filmaker and
you are one of the best and if micro Mo
stage something that would be a big
disaster and the same applies to other
fields like the for the games if you
make a game with documentary people will
say oh it it's just a game is nothing
serious and for the like the radio is
the same for the radio drama the war of
the wars first came the people don't
think that's a drama it's just thinking
about the Martians are invading our
world so what do you think about this
and do you think are you thinking about
educating the audience or inter interact
with
them can we say both sure I mean I the
one idea I would put forward is this
very basic journalistic concept of
transparency where you can kind of do
anything as long as you tell the
audience what you're doing and
uh it's a very simple idea but it's
actually hard to do in practice and
certain projects become very difficult
to tell the audience what's going on
here like if there's a real mashup
between fiction and non-fiction and how
are you going to explain to people what
what's real and what's not and some
pieces we can't work with because
they're just too complicated other
pieces you come up with a very creative
solution like we did this musical mashup
piece where there were real lines spoken
by Mitt Romney turned into a musical
song and we wind up having an online
article that went with it with all the
lyrics and links to every line so you
could see the original video
clips oh so sourcing Everything To
Source it that's what that was
so they're sometimes they're Creative
Solutions but I think we have a lot of
responsibility but it does beg the
question I mean so one of the problems
if you look at the market erosion that
the buzz feeds Vice voxes have had it's
because they're working with Niche
audiences in a sense where they can kind
of they kind of know what the literacy
level is technologically as well as
aesthetically even in ways where I think
all of you here are working with
probably broader audiences that are more
broadly conceived the audience that
you've had the the the true viewers of
uh Frontline as well as those who you
can do something different for the
online folks because they're probably
different but
how how nichy can you be and still do
the work you're doing in terms of your
imagination of the audience your
conception of the audience front Line's
very small so there's only a few of us
making you know bigger decisions about
um what we do and one of the interesting
things um is coming to front line you
know it is 30 years old so it is old um
it's people would be like well Frontline
doesn't do that and I would look around
and say well where's Frontline wait
aren't we Frontline you know and so this
really opened up a whole dialogue about
what are we who are we which may be a
little bit different if you have a huge
institution where um you have so many
different departments but for us it was
um just freeing up the conversation
about what we could do and that was the
crucial turning point and you know also
the other big difference is that
frontlines always streamed its filmed
very early so you know David Fanning has
always believed in being digital first
so there's never been a sort of
restriction on that front but I do think
that we still maintain some very strong
journalistic rules especially I mean we
could talk about some of this tomorrow
it's really interesting provocative
moments that we've been faced with where
we've had to like Jason said just say
sorry we can't do that you know it's not
going to work for
us yeah Sean
um hello uh I'm curious if um you could
talk a little bit about if you've if any
of you have kind of encountered
resistance within your organizations
particularly around kind of some of the
more experimental interactive work um
and particularly at times when it's you
know kind of costly like how how are you
kind of weighing the sort of cost
benefit um and the sort of balance
between the traditional work that you've
done whether it's print journalism or
long form video and you know some of
these forms that are a little bit um
more kind of um untested and and aren't
always guaranteed to reach audiences or
the audiences that you might expect um
well generally there's a kind of
confusion about what these are so when I
work with a journalist or with an editor
or um they want to first thing they want
to know is what it's going to be um and
what they need to do and you say well
we're still working on the concept and
not entirely sure what it's going to be
yet um that's really confusing for
journalists cuz they're so used to
having a very clear brief so I was
working with a journalist on a
Bangladesh project earlier this year and
he just wanted to know you know how many
words literally and what they what I
roughly wanted them to say um so he
delivered I think about um he delivered
about 10,000 words to me in the end
which I used about three 3,000 words of
and he was you know quite upset about
that
but when he saw the piece at the end and
it all came together he understood that
you know the writing had formed you know
the whole structure of the piece and the
data and the graphics that went in all
came from his writing but it's quite
confusing um for for for journalists to
to understand the process that it's
going to take six months to make um and
and what you need from them and how
they're going to fit into it I say
there's less resistance about um lots of
people I find at the guardian anyway
everyone wants to get involved in making
these things because they they see them
as being kind of shiny and sparkly and
yeah we want to be part of of making one
of these but they don't they just don't
kind of understand really what they are
um and also I think that there you know
the New Media are is is you know when I
when I started working in multimedia and
the guardian I was being asked kind of
you know how how why are they funding
these radio Studios and TV studios that
they're building the guardian why this
is very expensive actually journalism is
expensive investigative journalism
expensive and you know why in a way why
do we need to um justify this different
part of Journalism when you know there's
a huge amount of of of cost for the for
the guardian how exists and I think that
that is now being seen as you know the
all of these different elements are part
of the way that we tell stories and and
report and and that we don't need to
justify ourselves just because we're a
new addition we do not need to justify
ourselves one of the things I've really
been I've liked a lot in the guardian is
the way that it offers links to readers
so an article will I mean it's usually
your own articles or it might be a
interactive data set but the way in
which you're able to sort of remine your
morg in a sense stuff that that's
that popped up two or three weeks ago
but it'll still get linked up as a as a
subhead that you can go to if you want
to know more about the story turning
even ordinary print stories into a more
interactive uh as in as in hyperlink
within the Tex we absolutely been
encouraged to do that since we went
online because it's seen as a a hugely
important part of telling that story
yeah it makes great use of your other
resources allows users to sort of deepen
their knowledge of of the story yeah I
put a link in yesterday to a guardian
article and there were
competitors was the best
article
yeah um so my question is somewhat
related to the earlier question um which
is uh well I feel like I'm one of the
early adopters that cat talked about I'm
a software developer so you know when I
go and check out this story that M nfb
put up I'm really excited about the
technology um and and I'm wondering how
do
organizations decide the impact of these
New Media pieces and and I know you know
people understand intuitively that you
know the audience is changing and we're
moving away from just you know text and
like you know younger people want to see
more but how do we really know that you
know and and what are the metrics are
there any standard metrics that
organizations are coming up with to
measure the effectiveness and the impact
of New Media
stories
That's The $64,000 Question
Bingo we know how many people click on
them um sometimes we know how long they
spend on them um i' would say that
success for a project isn't always just
how many hits there are because like if
we put up a a panda photo gallery it is
going to get a lot more hits than an
interactive about the Bangladesh
clothing industry that I've spent six
months on it's just and the guardian
knows that you know it knows that if it
wants lots of hits you know it needs put
you know kit kitten galleries will do it
um and I think it does have a lot of
Integrity as an organization that that's
not we don't only meas measure success
through through hits um so these
specific interactives has seen their
successes also on how it's kind of
regarded within you know within these
circles how they're peer reviewed um
but most importantly I think whether
just internally whether we think they
tell stories well and that's incredibly
subjective but in the end of the day you
know we're the guardian is looking
around at different ways of telling
stories whether it's through Twitter
whether it's through live blogs whether
it's through interactives and it's
looking at them going actually does that
do we think that works or not and if it
doesn't um then it will kind of throw it
out of the way I mean Guardians has been
very kind of agile since it became
digital just like trying loads of stuff
um in a quite kind of haphazard chaotic
way seeing what sticks onto the wall and
the rest kind of falls off and I guess
we we we look at these projects and go
does this tell this story well and if so
we'll try and do more of them and we'll
try and do them better um so yeah that's
for the guardian that's probably our my
answer I would say we judge everything
the same way we judge our films and our
tra more traditional film making is it's
the same thing it's it's similar in the
sense that you do know how many people
come to it but um most journalistic news
organizations don't just base everything
on the numbers or we would do pandas but
you do care about the form and I think
that's you know another reason to be an
MIT is to really sort of crack the code
on what's the right form for for a news
organization like Frontline right
there's going to be a special sort of
Storytelling that we do that's going to
be different and the other thing I would
say is that a a lot of the um most
recent work that is interactive that
I've I've appreciated the most is when
it is crossplatform with other news
organizations and that's when I've seen
the biggest impact is frankly when we're
working with two or three other news
organizations and then you just see not
just the numbers but the engagement go
through the roof because we're
presenting it so many different ways and
that's where I get really excited I
think that's
crucial I know that at the national film
Board of Canada our mandate isn't just
to reach wide audiences it's it's an
important part of what we do um but it's
also to try and understand um the social
impact beyond what you can measure at
the at the keyboard and I know that um
that you at MIT are doing a project on
measuring how how organizations are
measuring impact so there's really
important work being done here in in
collaboration with TFI uh about how to
measure Beyond those numbers those
qualit quantitative numbers and look at
a broader uh deeper social impact social
policy impact um impact on sens
sensitivity trading or education all all
those very difficult things to tangibly
uh measure so impact is stuff to is very
tough to report on exact that's one of
the biggest challenges is what is impact
and that's very subjective too so what
we think is impactful will be very
different than another news organization
or even a citizen what they think is
impactful so that's that's another
that'll be your challenge Philip Napoli
was here a couple of weeks ago I don't
see him he'll be here tomorrow in any
case and he spoke um I mean he made a
really good point that the very fact of
a journalistic organization the fact
that a community has a newspaper whether
it's read or not the fact that it exists
is already deterrent to all kinds of
egregious behavior for fear that it
might show up in other words it's not
about reading the story or the expose
it's about the fact that there could be
the expose that has people so what
they've been doing is looking at
communities with papers and news
communities without to sort of give this
some substance and um but it's an
interesting again one of those things we
don't usually think about with impact
the fact that there's a newspaper there
but that was one of my first print
experiences we started a a a newspaper
in the James Bay Cree region in the nine
cre communities um and uh before then
there had never been uh a newspaper
there never an ink covering the news in
that area it was always radio journalism
and within three years I think all the
leadership in all the communities had
had fallen because of the impact of the
newspaper w wow that's
great
hi I'm um the digital editor at lont in
Paris and I'm a neon fellow and we
struggle with the same thing as you guys
and I was following up on on the
question about data but don't you have
ways to meter to monitor data inside
interactive feates to see how people
choose or click on stuff I mean not not
only the figures I mean how much people
click on stuff but how um and not only
how long they stay on the page but what
they do and and and then my question is
uh what kind of lessons do you have from
this I mean do you decide when you say
we we put a lot of stuff on the web and
we see what sticks on the wall we do
exactly the same thing but when we have
a hard time but then we have a hard time
to determine if something sticks on the
wall can we deploy something from this
can we like have an industrialized way
to do this stuff again and again because
it works well with the audience and most
of the time it doesn't so I was
wondering if you had any experiences of
this
timee I do know that Knight came in to
fund us on one of our big um new efforts
and they're actually saying that we need
to actually answer that question in part
they want to know how much can you learn
about what users are doing with what
they're experiencing so I think that
that's like a whole new wild west of
really understanding what people do once
they're experiencing something Beyond
how long they stay and how many people
come and it's it is the impact question
it comes down to that again and now
there's a couple of these audience
development groups that are actually
specializing and helping us figure that
out so I mean it's I think it's really
rich territory to understand that I
think key to what we believe as
journalists though which is the
interesting Coral are is we still have
to do work right regardless of what we
think the audience wants I mean not as
simple is do we put a panda bear up
who's so cute but you know there are
often times that we come we we're doing
journalism that we don't really know
that the public would even know about
you know and we don't we know they're
not going to watch it in droves but we
think it's important so I think that's
like one of the things I hope we can
keep near and dear as we learn more and
more about audience usage is is that
tradition of
Journalism um the earnest side you know
I think
whoever maybe it's from the open dock
lab but who whoever could carve out a
niche in understanding this would have a
a great job and that every every news
organization will need somebody like I
would love to have this like consultant
on hand and every morning I go in and
say show me the boards and they put up
you know and you know ex they are
starting to do
that but it's it's hard should say that
new well we have we have these analytics
groups and I can request reports and
they're really cool with like pie charts
and stuff saying what percentage of
people are coming from social and mobile
and which countries and but what's often
hard to understand is why people like
how do you interpret the data like you
can understand how long people are on a
site and stuff like that but why are
they making certain decisions right now
I'm trying to find out a commenting
question like why aren't there more
comments like there's got to be more
comments is it a design issue a
technology issue do people just really
not have much to say about this issue I
thought they had a lot to say but you
know kind of it's hard maybe we need
focus groups rather than analytics maybe
it's old school I mean it's a classic
it's a classic Paradigm battle between
the quantitative qualitative approach
one's really easy to generalize but the
other but it's kind of thin and the
other is terrifically deep but what do
you do with it you just built a un slap
which I mean this is before rather than
after launching but this is a huge thing
for the guardian to actually you know
kind of care that much about how people
are going to interact with these things
not just interactiv with the whole
website um which kind of you know tracks
the eye movement and you know what
people are doing with their Mouse and
where they're moving on the screen and
so they test out various parts of you
know the football site for instance
they've just done this huge case study
on you know where people are are moving
the mouse and if they design the the the
homepage in different ways what happens
so they there is a kind of they are kind
of moving in that direction but it's
it's quite expensive and specialist as
you know and um takes quite a lot of
investment as
well I was wondering if any of you had
any insight on kind of future of where
we're going to get financing for these
projects especially once they start
getting more complicated with oculus
rift and and and if there's maybe kind
of a a fee for for accessing these kind
of documentaries or or short form um
projects um once they do start costing a
lot more um so that's my question I
think that's actually a great question
that's come up um and amongst the
fellows a lot um in the open doc lab
that I think and William and I have
talked about this that one of the um the
things we've seen in documentary in
general is that the costs have been
going down right so production has just
been less and less expensive as cameras
have gotten smaller and one person can
shoot and produce and so this is the
opposite direction and so if I were you
I would identify the news organizations
um or the small centers of in inovation
that are starting to pop up practically
everywhere and and start pitching but
pitch with a really good idea um what's
been interesting for us is that we get
huge amounts of pitches on for films
just linear films we get pitched all day
long every single day but on the
interactive side um the stories and I
think it may have to do with something
that you you you were talking about
which is it's so hard to describe these
projects before you build them that I
would just counsel people who want to
start making interactive films or
whatever you want to call them to be
able to describe them at least a little
especially to somebody like me that
would be awesome like I and I really
have had these amazing circular
discussions oh sorry about that um in
which I I haven't really understood what
it is that the person wanted to do
enough to even understand if we could
potentially fund them and that's a big
challenge I know before you built it and
you would speak to that more eloquently
than I could but I do you think that
would be
helpful and a few pictures too like just
a few little handro sketches and wi
frames just that would help too really
helps when you're pitching yeah a
visuals a visual pitch helps in these
cases really really
truly
Andrew hi uh I just want to go back to a
comment that I think that Jason made
just a few minutes ago talking about why
aren't there enough comments or more
comments I was I thought about uh a Pew
research uh study that just came out a
couple weeks ago talking about how
social media is really creating Twitter
Facebook's creating these Echo Chambers
in so much they become empty chambers
that's why maybe potentially there's a
lack of comment so I'm wondering if the
idea of trying to and and be and the
result I mean the study from that talked
about how that was maybe with the result
of feeling like they're uncomfortable to
say something in their own opinion
because in these in Facebook and Twitter
we're allowed to surround ourselves with
like Minds right so we're not it's we
don't want to be challenged by the
opposing views I'm wondering if folks in
the panel or even folks in the room if
there are research or other studies
that's happening to really find a way to
get the conversation happening between
polarizing issues you know how can we
get Fox News audience to watch CNN and
CNN to watch Fox and so forth to really
have a real debate someone just
wondering if if there's any work on that
space I think if people um trust the
organization like like with the times uh
when we have published opds on
immigration
issues filmmakers have often been
surprised at the number of conservative
comments they were maybe thinking they'd
be in a in a kind of home team crowd but
in fact you know some very uh passionate
sometimes well argued
commentary kind of slamming the probably
the position of the filmmaker so I think
that's a that's a healthy sign that what
we're doing has enough Integrity that
it's a safe space for for opposing
arguments
but that that's that's what I
see that P research was really
provocative it's it's it's hard to see
that happening but I do think there's
you know especially with younger people
they don't even really identify with a
new organization so I imagine that these
forums are going to happen apart from us
to a large degree where you know multi-
opinioned formats and forums are going
to start to pop up because curious young
people are going to want to create them
I mean that's another way to look at it
as I hope those types of forums are
created the guardian seems to get some
amount of those those debates that span
political stances and I think it's
because in part it's a British thing but
it's also time of day like you can sort
of see when the Americans are awake and
they come into the do I mean they
usually often self descri if it's a hot
enough topic they'll self- describe as
and um and then they'll get British
responses I mean but it's a space for
robust debate very often and it's
interesting because the you know the
guardian reader is such a stereotype and
yet online it seems to have got a much
wider audience um which I think it's
been very you know very pleased to see
that you know what we're all trying to
do is in widen our audience and that it
is
possible that's true for front line too
so question about data visualization and
interactive data visualization um we've
got the tools we've got the data that's
certainly a growth area what kind of
uses are you find are you finding that
are those helpful developments or are
those just ways to parse what's
uh so I think easily available I think
our challenge as kind of interactive
documentary makers is to make them um
kind of emotional and meaningful because
there are some amazing data
visualizations out there but because
they don't have narrative and the kind
of time element to them they can feel
very dry and very cold and um I actually
think that's probably the next step for
for all of us is is how to bring
narrative and emotion into to data Vis
which I think is is such huge potential
there for us
um but there hasn't been that much done
um I don't think I I don't think that
really grabs you by the heart and pulls
you in yeah right now it's mostly seems
to be framing strategies to sort of make
you understand why the data is
relevant there was one that you guys
showed about gun control that was so
emotional I wish we had it up here Sarah
do you remember maybe you can shoot it
around to people are Sean it was
unbelievable if you if you all take a
look at this you'll see what you're
talking about the potential of having
data Vis actually touch you was I was
shocked by that what what is it called
what's it's periscopic it's a data
visualization Studio it's really worth
looking at it's it was really quite
something and I mean you probably it's
on our moments of innovation website
there's the data Vis from the mid 19th
century Menard's visualization of French
troops going into Russia and coming back
and it's sort of beige and robust
marching in and it's a timeline as well
as a
a Terrain map and what goes in really
huge comes out as a trickle and it's a
it's a tearjerker of a I mean I there
aren't that many data visualizations
that bring tears to your eyes and this
is one that does the trick with me
anyway
umis okay periscopic it's really short
but it'll just it'll it's really quite
something guns. periscopic
it'll trouble you I just stepped out so
maybe you somebody asked the question I
was going to ask so we've been talking
about Technologies but primarily
interactivity so lots of other things
have happened to journalism in the last
20 years and visualization is one uh the
ways in which mapping and so forth and
representation of content through Visual
uh delivery there's so many different
things that have happened so I'm just
wondering what maybe two or three other
major areas of change and shift uh uh
through Technologies and uh Innovations
uh are on your
minds i' like to I like to give a really
crude example um just because it's a
really nice counter to what I do which
is um kind of Journalism by Twitter like
one of our um one of our journalists
John Henley who actually wrote The
Beautiful text for Firestorm also did a
whole load of reporting using Twitter
getting people to send him to different
places to to do the reporting and
actually during London riots as well
another one of our reporters did that it
was basically being being fielded around
London by people using Twitter and you
know I think that uh that technology can
in in really cheap and kind of quite
crude ways be really powerful in terms
of where it's driving
journalism did you mean additional
technologies that impacting journalism
or just different yeah uh technologies
have changed the way journalists uh
there was an article in uh the globe
Sunday I won't remember the title of it
but it was just about reporting in the
Middle East and how uh uh reports are
coming in from people who aren't don't
even consider themselves journalists who
are putting together information from a
variety of sources and how their
information is better than anybody
else's but uh the problem is is checking
it and getting it accurate because it's
the professional element is isn't there
but you know there there are these
changes these organic changes that are
taking place in this this terrain and so
I'm just curious about what you see as
uh one or two the the thing I would
mention is drones drones is amazing I
got there I'm working with this
filmmaker who's in China with this
incredible footage that I thought was
like stock footage this aerial footage
it's like where did you license that
footage he's like oh no I shot that
footage with a
drone I got the best drone operator
and it's like wow that's impressive
really they were like the airp they
didn't like it in security though
because they're called a drone that's
the other thing we got to rename those
things something
else quadcopters exactly beautiful and
journalists are I know that times has
been thinking about how to use them for
news coverage for a lot of interesting
things you could do in terms of you know
like measuring sizes of crowds or all
sorts of news Gathering applications but
the laws are are iffy there domestic
drones are not permitted in a lot of
situations and I would just argue that
um the the pushin technology and these
new technologies that are challenging Us
in so many ways in our daily lives and
in our professional and and working
lives um beyond the technology I think
what's really important to remember is
how it's shifting our entire methodology
as a documentarian I think uh what the
New Media has afforded just like you say
is citizen journalism participatory
methods that really challenge some of
the the the Troublesome and troubling
elements of our practice of this the
exploitative um uh ways in which we have
told told stories um the way in which
certain voices have been shut out of
stories all those really deep questions
that these Technologies are making us
face um is really important and it and
also breaking down the boundaries um and
the silos between journalism and
documentary and even fiction and I would
argue uh going beyond that looking at
how for me documentary um can work with
theater and can work with performance in
in really deep and profound ways that
that uh that renew some old traditions
and create new ones in in the way that
we search for meaning and and Justice
Kat that's those are like eloquent
closing words for this session I mean
really that's great that hits the nail
on the head thanks hey want to thank the
panel and um
[Applause]